Mm,
so when you're.
We're fascinated with your election,
hillary and trump,
goodness,
and everybody that you talk to says,
well,
how is trump being so successful?
Why on earth are people tolerating
sexist,
racist,
hate speech,
and there was a good answer for it.
I wrote a piece recently for time and I
discussed why trump is having the sort
of success that he's having at the
moment and it comes down to one thing.
Trump is a troll that has jumped off the
internet and into the real world and the
reason that so many people are tolerant
of his extreme statements is name
calling this horrible,
nasty even stood sadistic behavior is
because the online environment has
normalized this type of behavior
in cyber psychology.
We pointed out that what happens in the
cyber world impacts on the real world.
What happens in the real world impacts
on the cyber world,
and this is certainly true in terms of
trump's behavior.
There's a great study titled Trolls.
Just want to have fun and you should
read this because it talks about the
dark tetrad of personality.
The study found that people who say that
they like to troll actually score high
on an an index that measures
machiavellianism and index that measures
psychopathic traits and index that
measures narcissistic traits and say
doesn't,
and the study found that trolling was a
manifestation of everyday sadism.
And election aside,
I know it's important,
but I'm more concerned about a bigger
issue.
The issue is that people like me spend
our time trying to teach kids to be nice
to each other online,
but it's very hard for us to win that
battle when politicians use cruelty and
sadism as a strategy and appear to gain
ground because of it.
So cyberspace is an environment.
It's somewhere where you go.
It's an immersive environment chatroom
forum.
It's a place.
And what happens there is that behavior
can become normalized.
So as human beings,
we're social creatures and we learn from
others.
So for peers that everybody is doing
something,
it can seem that it's okay and it's
become very difficult with the pervasive
penetration and accessibility of the
Internet to draw the line between
something that's in evolving behavior
and that's become almost a social norm.
And sadly,
online trolling has become almost a
social norm.
The problem is when that behavior cyber
migrates into the real world and trump
and the way he behaves is a classic
example of cyber like ration.